Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Incredible Hulk breakdown
video with all new details and Marvel
phase 4 Easter eggs and connections that
we missed the first time we saw it since
we're all in lockdown we're rewatching
all the Avengers infinity saga MCU
movies finding new Easter eggs teasers
for the upcoming movies if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos as part of this series
we're doing a new infinity saga box that
giveaways for all the blu-rays all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and participate with your favorite
things from Incredible Hulk that set up
the future movies careful for spoilers
from all the Marvel movies so far all
number of these Easter eggs a little
differently as we go through the movie
from start to finish looking at the
Incredible Hulk now it's a bit of a
weird situation it's one of those early
Marvel phase 1 movies when Marvel
Studios was still trying to figure
itself out and build up to an Avengers
crossover so early on they knew that
they wanted the Hulk and they tried the
Hulk with a Lee's movie earlier that did
okay but they wanted to do a more
hardcore approach to the character a
darker version of the Hulk the original
angley film was a little more
psychological it took forever for him to
actually turn into the Hulk so they just
blow through that during this film they
crank the action way up and in fact
Edward Norton who would later infamously
part ways with Marvel allowing Mark
Ruffalo to take over as the Hulk in the
first Avengers movie recently revealed
the full story of what their original
plans were for his Hulk a trilogy of
movies with a dark version of the Hulk
way more hardcore something more akin to
the tone of the immortal Hulk comic book
right now without all the big cosmic
stuff in speaking of Mark Ruffalo he'll
obviously figure into this as we talk
about future Hulk Easter eggs but the
director of the movie Lewis Lettieri as
original choice for Hulk during
Incredible Hulk was Mark Ruffalo but the
studio Kevin Feige Marvel and Universal
decided on Edward Norton just because he
was a more bankable name at the time
that's why when it came time to recast
The Hulk for The Avengers movie when
Edward Norton left they went straight to
Mark Ruffalo because he was originally
on the short list to be Hulk for
incredible hulk the beginning of the
movie forgoes the traditional origin
story just by giving you a montage
showing you his gamma experiments the
accident that turned him into the hulk
this will be key for later when general
Thunderbolt Ross starts talking about
the weapons Plus program
because he reveals that banners original
gamma experiments were secretly part of
the new version of the Super Soldier
program without telling banner what he
was working on the weapons Plus program
is just the higher version of what the
Super Soldier program became weapons
engineered by the military to create
better soldiers through various means
each different iteration of the weapons
Plus program gets a different moniker
Captain America is designation weapon 1
Wolverine who most people think of as
Weapon X is actually Weapon 10 the X
stands for Roman numeral 10 this is all
key for Marvel phase 4 and Marvel phase
5 set up that I'll reference later in
the video when talking about the new
movies and the Disney Plus series like
Falcon and Winter Soldier that pick up
on this weapons Plus storyline the
opening montage also mirrors the opening
scene from The Incredible Hulk 1970s TV
show exactly shot-for-shot during this
we meet our Betty Ross Liv Tyler for the
first time even though she hasn't come
back in the MCU the Russos did reveal
that she got snapped during infinity war
and she is alive in the MCU somewhere
she could always come back in cameo at
some point Liv Tyler actually took over
the role of Betty Ross from Jennifer
Connelly in the angley Hulk movie
Jennifer Connelly later married Paul
Bettany the vision the voice of Jarvis
during spider-man homecoming Jennifer
Connelly came back to do the voice of
Karen aka suit lady for spider-man's
stark tech suit in fact another big
actor from Incredible Hulk came back
during spider-man homecoming Martin star
who plays mr. Harrington in the
spider-man movie spider-man homecoming
spider-man far from home I think we can
assume that he's going to come back
during spider-man 3 Kevin Feige later
revealed that he's actually playing the
same character he said that this
character an Incredible Hulk is mr.
Harrington when they're flashing through
all the newspaper clippings you spot a
bunch of familiar names Rick Jones who's
a longtime Hulk comic book sidekick they
haven't really done in the movies yet
but they could always bring him in
future Hulk projects another big Hulk
comic book character Leonard Samson
appears who's played by Ty Burrell he's
more of a psychiatrist during this movie
but eventually in the comics he siphons
off some of Hulk's gamma gets powers and
becomes doc Samson this is a really big
Nick Fury Easter Egg here we've already
seen him in the first Iron Man movie
post-credit scene so we know who he is
we see the shield's logo show up on a
bunch of documents and websites remember
they're still setting up the MCU
in trying to build to the Avengers so
there's a lot of shield stuff all over
the place in this movie also in the
document is see it says Code Red threat
level red one of the many Red Hulk
Thunderbolt Ross Easter eggs in the
movie Incredible Hulk
during that opening montage you also see
Thunderbolt Ross raises hand up covered
in red some of the other documents are
schematics of Stark Industries weapons
that Thunderbolt Ross uses later in the
movie to try and subdue Hulk with those
special sound waves they used that same
technology against spider-man in those
drones during spider-man far from home
and it also showed up in Captain America
civil war inside roadies war machine
armor we meet our Thunderbolt Ross for
the first time he's still active
military during the events of this movie
as he explained during Captain America
Civil War a few years before the events
of that movie he suffered the heart
attack and transitioned to his civilian
job as head of the world security
council making him even more influential
and powerful Thunderbolt Ross today is a
much bigger character and will continue
to be a big part of the MCU through
future Hulk stories in the Disney Plus
series like the Thunderbolts and a Red
Hulk storyline that are slowly setting
up using the Disney Plus series like
Falcon and Winter Soldier William hurts
that a long time ago one of the main
reasons why he took the role in the
Marvel movies was because he was a huge
whole comic book fan and based on what
Edward Norton said about a lot of their
original plans for his character pre
Mark Ruffalo Hulk change it sounds like
he might have eventually become the main
villain of the final Hulk movie in there
Hulk trilogy a lot of this evidence also
comes from the leader character played
by Tim Blake Nelson who gets his comic
book origin story at the end of the film
he says that his character was
originally going to be the villain of
the sequel and in the comics he's the
character who turns Thunderbolt Ross
into Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross is going
to appear during the Black Widow movie
as we've all seen during that trailer
although it's a slightly different
version of the character the timeline is
a little bit weird and he looks like a
very different version of the character
that we've seen before he's using a cane
but it looks like they've digitally
de-aged him to make him look younger
even though this is happening after
Captain America Civil War and this is
what he looked like during that movie
all just more clues about their plans
for Thunderbolt Ross storyline in Marvel
phase 4 then before they actually pick
up in Brazil there was going to be a
deleted scene that they took out of the
movie where Edward Norton's Hulk tries
to kill himself with a gun down in the
polar icecaps when that happened he
actually turned into the Hulk created a
giant shock wave that unearthed get it
Captain America and his shield because
remember this movie came out a couple
years before the Captain America movie
it was also before they had cast Chris
Evans as Captain America but the
Incredible Hulk movie is littered with
Captain America Easter eggs and set up
because they did way more of that during
the early Marvel phase one movies there
was way more crossover and set up in
each movie the more recent Marvel movies
have tended to be a little more
self-contained and usually the big
teaser moment setting up other movies
are relegated to post credits scenes at
the end of the movie the movie then
references the angley Hulk movie when
Bruce Banner shows up in Brazil South
America at the end of angley's Hulk film
it was implied that he was running
around somewhere in South America on the
TV you notice that he's watching Bill
Bixby David Bruce Banner of the original
Incredible Hulk TV show remember he was
David Banner on the TV show not Bruce
Banner even though he was playing the
comic-book character we find out that
he's working in a soft-drink factory
they have a funny moment where his blood
slips into a bottle he tries to stop it
from making it out they pay the
reference off during the Stan Lee cameo
later when he drinks some of that soda
in its imply that he Hulks out there's a
big thing about people trying to steal
Hulk's blood hoax DNA during this movie
to use it to replicate more super
soldiers that's also a big Easter Egg
for she-hulk too who got her powers when
she received a blood transfusion from
Bruce Banner in the comics right now
Marvel is making a she-hulk Disney Plus
series it's set to star Mark Ruffalo as
the Hulk so it sounds like they're going to
try and do a comic book version of her
origin story when that debuts the Ford
Johnson the Thunderbolt Ross is working
out up is named after Kenneth Johnson
the creator of the 1970s Incredible Hulk
TV series we see Emil Blonsky for the
first time aka the abomination and even
though we haven't seen the abomination
since the Incredible Hulk movie Marvel
did confirmed that he's still alive they
could always bring him back at some
point for Thunderbolts or just depends
on what they want to use the character
for during our next big Hulk out seeing
you also noticed that the way they
filmed this is very similar to the way
that they've filmed Mark Ruffalo's first
transformation into the Hulk during the
Avengers movie almost as if it were a
horror film filming him from the shadows
from the perspective of the people who
are running away from him like Black
Widow when Edward
Norton was talking about his vision for
a darker Hulk trilogy he was talking
about stuff like this
filming Hulk as if it were more of a
horror film the closest thing we're
going to get to a horror film in the MCU is
actually going to be Doctor Strange 2
multiverse of madness which is being
directed by Sam Raimi mr. spider-man himself!
Pizza time.
Banner changes back walking through the
streets in his shredded pants they play
the classic theme song from The
Incredible Hulk TV series again and we
get our infamous Super Soldier weapons
Plus scene where Thunderbolt Ross
explains how he's dusted off the Super
Soldier program and has big plans for it
in the future
Banner's work was very early phase
it wasn't even weapons application he
thought he was working on radiation
resistance I would never have told him
what the project really was and
something very wrong.
Or it went very right!
This is all Marvel creating backstory for characters
like Wolverine in the MCU through the Weapon
X program setting all that stuff up
laying seeds for Marvel phase 4 Marvel
phase 5 even though at the time they
filmed this marble did not have the
rights to the character in Fox was
getting ready to release Wolverine
Origins but just a little while before
this earlier in the years when they
released the Iron Man movie there was a
deleted scene where they mentioned
mutants x-men spider-man so it was clear
that Kevin Feige wanted to do Wolverine
in the MCU way back then the reason this
is a big deal creating a connection
between Wolverine and Hulk in the MCU is
because Wolverine debuted in the
Incredible Hulk comics number 181 you
notice outside Thunderbolt Ross's office
there's a picture of Captain America
because it's all about the Super Soldier
program setting up weapons Plus but it
was also before they cast Chris Evans in
the Captain America movie that didn't
happen till a couple years after this
movie was released we see that
Thunderbolt Ross already has a new
version of the Super Soldier Serum he's
going to inject the abomination with on
the tank it confirms the weapons Plus
program dr. Reinstein was the alias dr.
Erskine used in the Captain America
movie in the tech is made by Stark
Industries Howard Stark being one of the
pioneers of the Super Soldier program
Veidt arrays were also the original
method they used for irradiating Captain
America to give him his powers in the
comics like I said there is
much Captain America all over this movie
Bruce goes to Stanley's Pizza a
reference to Hulk creator Stan Lee the
owner of the restaurant is played by
actor Paul souls he was the voice of the
Hulk in the 1960s animated Hulk series
also did the voice of a bunch of other
animated Marvel characters then we get
our big Lou Ferrigno cameo when he takes
the pizza to the security guard he also
got a cameo during the angley Hulk film
and maybe they'll give him a cameo
during she-hulk or if they do an
Incredible Hulk Disney Plus series
because Mark Ruffalo did say that they
have the rights to do an Incredible Hulk
TV series so he's been pitching one to
Marvel we have our big Hulk battle with
Thunderbolt Ross and Blonsky on the
campus using those stark tech sonic
cannons the two kids who record the
fight on their phones are big comic book
Easter eggs this one on the left is Jim
Wilson he's another sidekick like Rick
Jones the other is Jack McGee who's a
reporter from the 1970s Incredible Hulk
TV show who kept trying to chase down
the Hulk to do reports on him their
footage is actually used by whi H in a
news broadcast later that's the same
organization that they used in the other
Marvel movies like Captain America Civil
War
Betty takes banner back to her house she
brings in those giant purple stretchy
comic-book pants he just laughs and says
no thanks I'll take my chances
the shield logo shows up on another
computer terminal and they reveal Samuel
Sterns aka the leader Marvel has said
that his character is still alive in the
MCU but they haven't said whether or not
they plan to bring him back or to the
abomination currently those characters
are just sitting in a prison somewhere
on ice when Blonsky comes to force him
to give him more of Hulk's gamma blood
more power he literally says the name
abomination we have our big hero moment
when he jumps out of the plane knowing
that he won't die when he hits the
pavement because he'll Hulk out later in
thor ragnarok they used this as a joke
when Mark Ruffalo's Hulk has this big
hero speech then jumps out of the ship
and just splats on the Bifrost and just
sits there for a hot minute before
changing
During their big fight Hulk finally says
Hulk smash for the first time his
trademark catchphrase they later brought
that back around during the Avengers
movie when Captain America says Hulk
smash they brought the joke back around
again during Avengers end game only this
time they played it for comedy because
he was Professor Hulk and he says yeah I
don't know this feels kind of gratuitous
but maybe I should smash some stuff
Maybe smash a few things along the way I
think it's gratuitious, but whatever.
While this fight is going on you also
notice a Michael K Williams minor cameo
he played Omar on the wire he's done a
bunch of other stuff too so Omar also
running around in the background while
this is all happening really cool
continuity Easter Egg too abomination
stabs hole through the chest while
they're fighting with one of his big
spikes Marvel has kept that scar on Mark
Ruffalo's Hulk this whole time in all of
his Marvel movies there's another big
Incredible Hulk TV series Easter Egg on
Betty's package there it's addressed to
David Banner and because obviously they
were trying to set up the first Avengers
movie using this now he meditates
implying that he can kind of control his
transformations into the Hulk when his
eyes start glowing green later Mark
Ruffalo would reference this by telling
The Avengers his quote unquote secret
that's my secret Cap.
I'm always angry.
Then we get our big
iron man post-credit scene revealing
that he's putting the Avengers team
together and teases Captain America
because that movie hadn't happened yet
saying that the Super Soldier program
was put on ice for a reason wink wink
Captain America literally being put on ice.
What if I told you we were putting a team
together
Who's we?
There's another Big Red Hulk Thunderbolt
Ross teaser when you see the drink he's
drinking is green just like the same
Cola drink Stan Lee was drinking with the
Hulk's blood earlier in the movie the
next big Thunderbolt Ross storyline
we're going to  see is going to happen during
Falcon and Winter Soldier where he
restarts the Super Soldier program again
the weapons Plus program that's a big
part of the plot of the series curtly
that's supposed to premiere in August
there may be some delay with that but
there'll be a bunch more Easter eggs
carried over from The Incredible Hulk
movie in what was going on during this
during that series so everyone let me
know in the comments if you spotted any
other big Marvel phase 4 Easter eggs or
Avengers endgame foreshadowing or any
other big details that you didn't notice
the first time you watch the movie my
next big infinity Saga video will be for
Iron Man 2 because we're going in
release order that video will post in
the next couple of days but leave all
your video requests in the comments
below
everyone click here for that big Iron
Man infinity saga video and click here
for my new guardians of the galaxy 3
breakdown video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe I'll see
you guys tonight!